Sarah is in Cincinnati hey Sarah how are
you I'm great Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up so I have a
question for you I wanted to possibly
maybe make some extra money and my
husband's a little skeptical and so he
says call Dave and air save ok what are
you wanting to do to earn extra money um
so um female or not female but um weight
loss and skin products for like a
company out right there the name of the
company you can if you want
it's called it works ok just like on any
level organization yes that's the reason
for your husband's skepticism yes it's
not that he doubts you and it's not that
he doubts that you could probably earn
some extra money and he loves probably
that you're willing to he doesn't think
this is going to work well yeah he just
um he's just very skeptical so he's not
that entrepreneur type like I am so he's
like you have a really good job you
should just be happy we're debt-free
besides the house we are like 75
thousand left on our mortgage and we've
gone to your classes we do the 15% into
the retirement and we combined income is
like 130
oh no risk I don't see it being very
high far as and so why are you doing
this um because I feel like I was meant
for more like I like like for selling or
something um I read like all your books
and all the videos are books and I'm
just like yeah what do you do what do
you do for a living now I want
purchasing crap elevators here in
Cincinnati and offers admin and history
business and there's like them for
growth and everything and so alright
here's what I would tell you alright I
think you need to stop and start
thinking about what if you wanted to
open your own business and use your
skills in the marketplace because your
entrepreneurial and you want to open it
as a side business and grow it to the
point that it could even replace your
full time job at some point you need to
kind of back up and whiteboard that and
say if I was going to do that and I can
do anything in the world I wanted to do
in time and money or no object right
that kind of a question then what would
I do okay
I don't know if the answer to that
question would be the thing you're
proposing okay I think this just came
across your path from a friend and it
scratched your itch your entrepreneurial
itch but you probably weren't sitting
around going you know I want to get in
the weight loss and makeup business I
want to hire and train salespeople for a
living in a high turnover environment
you probably weren't sitting around
saying that does that make sense if that
makes sense because that makes them so
it goes again I hear the the upside of
multi-level organizations is is that the
sky's the limit whatever you want to do
the downside is is they're so hyped up
and people that are in them drive the
rest of us crazy because we don't want
to talk to you when you're in them
because you drive us nuts you know what
I'm talking about and and the downside
is that kind of stuff and the downside
is is that you know people get into them
thinking oh I'd like to make a little
extra money I'd like to be
entrepreneurial and they really don't
realize what they're getting into in
that you basically if you're going to
make good money in a multi-level six
figures or more you're going to be
working on ton of hours nights and
weekends
you're going to be recruiting sales
people for a living
that's what you do you are in the
recruiting business there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing
inherently evil or bad about that and
you're going to be trained
in salespeople and you're going to be in
a high turnover environment because most
of them don't make it in that
environment it's a high turnover
environment and so if that is what you
want to do if that's your calling then
this is a good way to flesh out your
calling and it's a legitimate way to do
that but that's what you're dealing with
you're dealing with a high turnover
sales force that you're hiring and
training all the time and that is your
job it ain't makeup it's not weight loss
because the makeup and weight loss
doesn't sell itself and if you want to
get in and make the big money that's in
multilevel that's what you're doing and
I've got friends that make seven figures
in that business they do very very well
makeover me in dollars a year doing it I
but for every one of those I know a
thousand that didn't last ninety days
and ended up with six boxes of makeup in
their garage that they were paying on
their credit card for which you're not
going to do that I know that but um you
know you but but you just have to think
through what what what is it about this
that's appealing and would I have been
doing this if I started from scratch and
white boarded and led me into this and
it's okay if you want to do it I'm not
mad about it but I think that's that's
the thing and your husband is aware of
all the high turnover and hide
disappointment rate around multi levels
and that's what he's cynical about and
that's what he's kind of got his eyebrow
raised about going really you don't
really want to that and and so in in
that sense he's not trying to be a dream
killer he's just trying to say hey
really stop and think about what you're
getting into but if you want to give it
a run hey I'll support you on it and he
will too probably but but you just got
to have a real clear business mind about
how you want to do it what I want to do
is I want you to come to business
boutique November fourth and fifth which
is how our Christie writes I'll be
speaking there Donald Miller be speaking
there Christine Kane will be speaking
there Rachel Cruz will be speaking there
it's a two-day event in Nashville and
I'm going to give you a ticket right
back I'm gonna give you two tickets
bring one of your friends with you and
it's a it's an event equipping women to
make
money doing what they love it's ladies
that want to start and own and operate
their own business or already have
started and own and want to operate
their own business and some of them are
multi-level some of them are but a lot
of them are finding different ways to do
their dreams then multi-level so
business boutique
hold on I'll have Kelly give you a
couple tickets if you want to come to
Nashville on November 4th and 5th you're
coming as our guest this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better in the same
room to channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you